so today i was feeling kind of burnt out
from my deep dive analysis type video
and since you guys seem to enjoy my mimi
content just as much
if not more actually than my other kinds
i thought i'd make the
ultimate anime tier list i went into
tear maker and found a list of the top
50 most popular anime on my anime list
top 50 best just wouldn't be fun but
with 50 most popular
you've got some bad apples in there so
it's bound to be exciting
now before we get into this i'd like to
mention of course that this is in no way
a completely objective take on these
anime i'm simply here to
entertain and that is what i shall do
now let me take a sip of this energy
drink real quick
and let's begin okay now
okay what are these ads doing here i've
added blog send feedback
inappropriate how is the google ad going
to be in a oh my god
google really knows what they're doing
over at that headquarters wait let me
check this
out real quick okay now let's start
and okay what are these doing oh well
actually
no no no we can't we have to uh
actually no let's keep that there not
even joking around here but high school
dxd
deserves a spot in the goaded category
there's simply no other edgy anime that
will ever be more iconic than high
school dxd
the reputation it's built is absolutely
iconic it's just
it's just perfect okay next let's take
on everyone's favorite where
is it oh here we go uh oh
it's all right look sword art online
season 1 is notorious but in all honesty
the first part was
pretty interesting and original at the
time isekai
asuna is a vanilla but still great waifu
kirito was a cool overpowered
protagonist
but dear god season two god where is it
oh yeah you get a spot down here in your
own little category sitting in your own
little tear
may you rot in the deepest dungeon of
the deepest recesses of the
okay and actually come on let's get rid
of this category here who are we kidding
come on we're veterans
ognaruto would be goaded it would be a
masterpiece
if the 90 episodes weren't like entirely
filler
naruto shippuden is actually in a
similar situation it's
it's kind of like that you know that
grammarly ad you're getting everywhere
on youtube right now
not on my videos of course because i'm
not monetized
my god naruto shippuden is just like
that it's unnecessarily stretched out
i mean the entire last like 250 episodes
of the show is just the fifth great
ninja war arc
like just one arc plus a lot of filler
like
this sentence is grammatically correct
okay actually let me make a new category
here
there we go the netflix starter pack
the shows that you watch at the very
beginning of your anime journey thinking
they were really gas
really good but as you moved on from the
platform and kept watching more shows
you realize they weren't all that great
not bad
but not really that good either let me
see what deserves to go on here
and there we go you might disagree with
this but if you do
just know you might need to watch some
more anime
and actually now that we're on topic of
netflix let me tackle a couple more
shows that are on there but don't
necessarily fit into this category
no game no life it's a pretty
interesting isekai mario
powderman protagonist it's got a bit of
edgy to it honestly there's not much to
complain about
angel beats it's alright this might be a
hot take but
look angel beats is one of the most
iconic shows that will quote unquote
make you cry
but when you compare it to shows like
your lion april and clan ad it really
just pales in comparison for me
the show oftentimes gets distracted by
its kind of like fantasy elements and
i don't know it just didn't hit as hard
and speaking of your line april
i mean come on come on if you don't
think your line april is goaded
you don't have a heart period
and toradora look this might be a hot
take
but but look look but spoiler alert here
the way that the main characters became
a couple in the end of the show was just
super rushed it ruined the rest of the
show for me
the way that they barely subtly hint at
their romance and then fully throw it in
our faces at the end with them like
running away from home for each other
just went way too fast
and honestly it ruined that suspension
of disbelief for me
it just felt way too forced and honestly
the show could have gone far if it
wasn't so rushed but
sadly it was okay next oh god
fairy tale even worse
look if you like fairy tale you're
either a just got into anime
or b are five years old or
or c both the
excessive themes of friendship in fairy
tale age like the kid from home alone
they're truly just not good and once you
watch a lot of shonen you realize just
how typical
and really not outstanding fairy tale is
i used to love this show when i first
got into anime i thought fairy tale was
all the [ __ ]
but i hate to break it to you it's not
man there's a lot of shows in here okay
it's speedrun time let me get a sip of
my drink first
to get a little boost and let's go
oh what the heck how did this one escape
the netflix starter pack come on get
back in there
you're not special psycho pass
okay we went through a little speed run
let me explain all these choices
hunter hunter i mean you can't complain
with this show
i mean it's got a bit of problems with
pacing in the chimerian arc but other
than that it's really just astounding
i'm no fanboy or anything i wouldn't
even put it personally in my top 10 but
you have to recognize game when it's
there and i mean the show is incredible
code eos honestly the show would be
great if the ending weren't
so absolutely incredible i mean there's
a reason that
pulling a lelouch is like the ideal for
any main character in an anime nowadays
there's a reason that lelouch is the top
character by far
on my anime list the ending makes code
geass just
absolutely goated gurren lagann if you
haven't watched gurin logon
you should it's really good i mean
there's not much to say
if you've watched the show you probably
agree with me
future diary i watched this a long time
ago but i remember it being pretty
interesting
i mean among dark anime at least it
wasn't afraid to stretch those
boundaries and it had a pretty
interesting plot at that
it got kind of crazy at the end as well
and i don't know it kept me interested
throughout
bleach again is classic because it's of
course one of the big three
but the filler is just absolutely
horrible
bleach is arguably even more notorious
than naruto for the amount of filler in
it so i did have to demote it
tokyo ghoul i mean it was one of the
most popular anime of the 2010s easily
but along with the performance of season
2 it really just doesn't stand the test
of time very well
erased erased used to be all the talk
but similar to doradora the ending just
did not seem to fit perfectly right with
the rest of the show
leading up to the finale the tone is
really great but then it seemed to get
kind of rushed into making a main bad
guy for the show
and to me it just didn't sit right
elfin lead lied lead lied
dude i don't the only thing i can
honestly remember about this show
is that the first appearance of this
girl she's blown up heads and she's
naked
that's that's honestly all i could tell
you about this show it really just was
not very memorable for me
oh but i love it it has such dark themes
yeah okay i didn't
sorry i can't like every show you guys
like
high school of the dead oh
i mean like the show isn't good but
but just look just
look at that yeah
yeah yeah come on guys yeah
let's go
[Music]
attack on titan oh god my whole fan base
is going to cancel me if i don't put
this in masterpiece so
there you go it's goated are you happy
no but seriously i mean attack on titan
is goaded
i mean the fan base can get kind of
toxic sometimes but if you just look at
the show objectively
looking at the manga and how it's been
adapted into the anime as well it is
goaded it's to stand the test of time
and it's just really incredible
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses